Місяць підготовки… І от нарешті, за тиждень до місцевих виборів,
Бориспільська районна територіальна виборча комісія
затверджує кінцеві макети чотирьох бюлетенів.
З бюлетенем вам все зрозуміло? Даємо в друк?
Для України ці вибори є історичними і складними, адже
проходитимуть за оновленим виборчим законодавством.
Нова виборча система передбачає, що депутатів на місцевих виборах
обиратимуть за відкритими списками. Це означає, що слід
проголосувати не лише за партію, але й за кандидата від партії.
В комісіях сподіваються, що виборець нічого не наплутає
та прийде на дільницю підготовленим.
Люди, якщо вже прийшли на вибори, то вони розуміють,
за кого голосувати. Це не так, що вона прийшла на виборчі дільниці
і буде розбиратись, за кого голосувати. Це важко.
Кількість бюлетенів, які отримає на дільниці виборець,
різна і залежить від місця проживання.
Нічого не зміниться для громад із кількістю виборців до 10 тисяч.
За допомогою звичних бюлетенів обиратимуть міських, селищних,
сільських голів та депутатів місцевих рад.
Інакше - в більших населених пунктах, як, приміром, Бориспіль,
де обиратимуть ще й депутатів районної і обласної рад.
Тут буде чотири бюлетені, і виборці наочно побачать
реформу виборчого законодавства. Як правильно заповнювати
новий бюлетень, у спеціальному ролику розповіла ЦВК.
Зробіть позначку "плюс" або іншу в порожньому квадраті
навпроти назви цієї організації. Впишіть порядковий номер
кандидата в депутати, якого ви підтримуєте, у квадраті
з нанесеним трафаретом. Проголосуйте відповідально!
Будь-що у квадраті навпроти партії, згідно з новим виборчим кодексом,
вважається позначкою. Байдуже, буде це галочка, хрестик чи навіть
знак долара. Такий голос зарахують. Інакше з другою клітинкою.
Тут треба чітко вписати номер кандидата від партії.
Цифри треба наносити за трафаретом, як колись індекс
на поштових конвертах. Аналітик громадської організації "Опора"
Олександр Клюжев каже, що ознайомитись зі списком кандидатів
можна заздалегідь на сайті ЦВК.
Голосування за відкритими списками може здатись складним
та незвичним для виборців,  однак у майбутньому може посилити
партійні регіональні осередки.
Це на користь нашим партійним структурам, бо партії у нас
централізовані. Місцеві організації залежать фінансово, організаційно
і бюрократично від вузького кола керівного органу
на центральному рівні. Є сподівання, що через виборчу систему
виникнуть лідери всередині партій, які будуть  піднімати
рівень самих партійних інституцій.
У ЦВК тим часом прогнозують можливі помилки.
Зокрема, виборці можуть проголосувати лише за партію,
а за кандидата забути. Це не так страшно,
адже такий голос зараховується партії. Виборці також можуть
обрати одну партію, але кандидата -  від іншої політичної сили.
Тоді треба мати на увазі, що голос зарахується на підтримку партії,
а не кандидата.
Виборці можуть поставити цифру навпроти кандидата
і не поставити за партію. В даному випадку виборчий кодекс каже:
якщо навпроти партії не поставлена відповідна позначка,
то він недійсний.
Тобто наявність цифри лише біля кандидата говорить,
що бюлетень недійсний. І виборці можуть припускатися таких помилок.
Через вкрай короткі терміни підготовки до виборів
помилки очікують не лише від виборців,
але й від дільничних комісій. Аби їх прорахувати, в ЦВК вперше
перед виборами зробили моделювання голосування.
В Одесі дивились, як голосувати в умовах карантину.
В Києві моделювали підрахунок голосів.
Моделювання в Одесі про протиепідеміологічні заходи показало,
що зростатимуть черги на вході і час на голосування зростає
від однієї до двох хвилин. І час підрахунку буде суттєво довшим.
У Комітеті виборців України від початку старту кампанії
не стихають телефонні дзвінки від членів дільничних комісій.
Проблема в тому, що в новому законі не прописані чіткі правила,
за якими бюлетень вважається недійсним.
Додаткові роз’яснення ЦВК кожна комісія зможе трактувати по-своєму.
Через складність підрахунку голосів та тиск від кандидатів
це може стати проблемою.
Для членів комісії буде дуже складно рахувати.
Якщо раніше треба було рахувати за 10 партій, то тепер, наприклад,
за 10 партій і 10 кандидатів від кожної партії.
Тобто замість 10 математичних дій треба зробити 100 математичних дій.
Ми вважаємо, що вибори будуть серйозно заполітизовані.
Ми вже зараз бачимо, що масштаб кампанії не відповідає
традиційним витратам на місцеві вибори.
Він відповідає витратам на парламентські.
Дуже багато коштів в компанію вливається
І сама кампанія важлива для влади і для опозиції.
За міжнародною практикою, на перших виборах
після впровадження системи відкритих списків до 10% бюлетенів
вважаються недійсними. Схоже, в Україні цей показник
може бути більшим. За тиждень до виборів багато виборців
усе ще не знають про нові правила голосування.
Будете голосувати на місцевих виборах?
Так, плануємо.
А чули про новий виборчи закон, правила нові?
Ні поки що.
Ні, не знаю.
Знаєте, як правильно голосувати, аби бюлетень був дійсний?
Чесно кажучи, не дивився. Думаю, розберемся. Що тут такого.
А скільки бюлетенів буде?
Бюлетенів? 5, по-моєму.
Ви з Києва?
Так!
У Києві - два.
До речі, внаслідок реформи децентралізації
податки від місцевого бізнесу тепер залишаються в громадах.
А отже, вперше місцеві політики, яких обиратимуть українці,
матимуть чималий бюджет і повноваження, вказують оглядачі.
Попри традиційну недовіру до влади, українцям варто реалізувати
своє виборче право, прийшовши на вибори 25 жовтня.